bonjour alors c'est moi jean luc
mélenchon j'ai fait l'erreur de venir
jusqu'ici et maintenant je répondre à
toutes vos questions chez bolt
alors du coup
alors l'idée c'est que vous puissiez
prendre la première question la lyre et
après la sirène bon allez on commence
par la première question paul le poulpe
détruit ça tout seul c'est le personnage
de la série policière pour le poulpe
êtes vous pour un abaissement du vote à
16 ans alors la réponse est oui
bon il faut un mot d'explication parce
que ça arrive payer des gens qui disent
voir m 16 ans c'est trop trop jeune
bon j'entends l'argument en plus ce
n'est pas nouveau pour moi puisque j'ai
fait tellement vieux que j'étais là
quand le vote était même pas 18 ans bien
21 et comme son a dit le droit de vote à
18 ans il ya plein de gens qui disent ah
c'est pas raisonnable c'est trop jeune
d'accord
donc je suis habitué à la cette remarque
alors pourquoi 16 ans honnêtement je
j'accepte qu'on m'en parle
pas ce qu'on peut à 16 ans être
émancipée ce qui revient est majeur on
peut à 16 ans exercer l'autorité
parentale si on en diamants
parce que à 16 ans a droit de vote dans
les élections prud'homales donc des
élections professionnelles qui désigne
des juges qui arbitre les litiges entre
employeurs et employés
et puis 16 ans et la majorité pénale
avant on est jugé par la justice des
mineurs après on n'est plus dans le
cadre de la justice des mineurs d'accord
je vous donne tout ça comment tant
d'arguments pour dire là pourquoi 16 ans
on peut être considéré comme apte à
formuler un jugement politique de
questions bon pour son pays alors
j'admets que ce soit pas toujours le cas
et qui compliquait 5 à 16 ans elle pour
moi j'ai pas envie sais pas je n'ai pas
idée
donc dans mon projet il ya le vote
obligatoire mais le vote obligatoire
sera une contrepartie
l'abstention contrat
et surtout le vote ne sera pas
obligatoire entre 16 et 18 ans
donc la finale à son garde sa liberté de
dire bah moi je me sens pas prêt je ne
sais pas mais s'il se sent prêt ben il
le fait et on l'a menée puisque je viens
de dire il ya plein de raisons qui font
qu'un l'admets autre vote obligatoire si
on veut pas ça veut dire on est
sanctionné ah bah oui le vote
obligatoire c'est c'est à part dotée été
sanctionnés soit à une amende soit moi
je trouve ça se remet d'un travail
d'intérêt collectif voix ils savent de
bon assez tu veux pas mais tu peux y
aller voter blanc mais normalement une
société démocratique ça repose sur la
citoyenneté donc le fait que les gens
donnent leur avis et 10 donner des
mandats voilà alors un citoyen qui eux
qui votent pas c'est le citoyen qui ceux
qui seront inutiles à la société sais
pas vous mais j'ai dit encore une fois
il y aura le respect du fait que l'on
peut aller jusqu'à l'isoloir et puis
dire moi je n'ai pas d'avis ou je veux
pas je pas d'accord avec votre truc as
d'accord bon alors là sandor pch
légaliser le cannabis la réponse est oui
je suis pour légaliser le cannabis
d'abord parce que
la prohibition donne rien quel est
l'argument contre la légalisation du
cannabis et que le cannabis
est une drogue et que par conséquent on
peut pas en proposer la libre
disposition pour vous connaissez les
arguments contre une dormund remier
drogue c'est pas pareil
la coke
et le cannabis mais il ya des gens qui
disent toutes les drogues
devait être habilité pour les raisons
que je vais voter maintenant mais la
demande il s'agit du cannabis on se
comprend bien et pour une chose
donc pourquoi parce que on pense que si
on de faire éteindre les trafics et
convaincre que c'est pas une bonne idée
de fumer comme une cheminée d'usiné du
cannabis même si on sait que c'est pas
le cas le plus fréquent on va pas
raconter d'histoires mais quand même il
ya un nom de carnon non mullings non non
négligeable de gens qui aiment y vont un
peu fort et même beaucoup fort et ça
c'est destructeur faut pas raconter
d'histoires ça fait pas du bien
d'autres dans de plus que le cerveau est
jeune alors donc si on veut faire ça
sérieusement si on veut mener des
campagnes
mieux vaut mener des campagnes de
convulsions que des campagnes de
prohibition
d'autant que les campagnes de
prohibition 1 ça marche pas et 2 ça fait
perdre un temps et en argent fou parce
que les officiers de police parce que ça
existe figurez vous qu'ils sont contre
le la prohibition du cannabis et disent
que 60% des cas de contact d'autres en
policier une personne hein c'est pour
contourner les affaires de cannabis donc
le dise une perte de temps gigantesque
pour un résultat qui est insignifiant
parce que quand tu te fais crochet bon
c'est ça serait étonnante et ton sac est
que tu es barrettes de dans quoi donc
moi je vous dis ça j'en fume pas je vous
dis ça par réputation à c'est tout
voilà donc voilà pourquoi on pense que
la légalisation serait une méthode plus
efficace parce qu'elle va appuyer trafic
mais ce n'est pas le seul trafic que moi
je veux épuisé parce que je veux changer
le fonctionnement de la police est ce
que quelqu'un qui me posera une question
un peu plus tard mais en tout cas ça
c'est ma réponse à propos du cannabis
phoenix gt que voulez-vous changer pour
le bac monsieur mélenchon mélenchon avec
la revue
alors
comme le bal vient de changer parce que
vous me demandez je suis contre le bac
en par contrôle continu d'accord parce
que ça c'est plus un examen national et
à partir de mousse est plus un examen
national ben il va se produire ce que
vous devinez c'est à dire que toutes les
facs et toutes les écoles qui viennent
après le bac ou voudraient aller
organisons un concours d'entrée en
faisant un coup tu es bon c'est bien
vous avez le droit avec votre bac de
passer le concours d'entrée mais si vous
n'avez pas de bague ne passait pas non
plus le concours d'entrée donc sous les
cintres d'hypocrites pour maintenir
l'apparence du bac comme premier grade
universitaire mais qui se termine par un
concours d'entrée c'est d'ailleurs le
but qui est visé par ce qui réorganise
l'éducation nationale depuis dix ou
vingt ans c'est de faire un marché de la
connaissance avec abyss mans qui vendent
du savoir avec un chef d'établissement
qui est un manager qui choisit les profs
et même certains disent qu'ils
choisissent le programme c'est déjà le
cas dans le collège des intentions du
collège programme du collège c'est le
s'est décidée par le collège suis
absolument contre tout ça je suis pour
que tous vous passerez même bakhta mêmes
conditions et que à la fin et pas vous
dire ah oui vous c'est un bac de khafji
c'est vrai tu regardes sur la carte pas
très bien placé pas bien femmes et bref
au lieu d'avoir diplôme qui vaut partout
bêta un motif de ségrégation
supplémentaires donc même battre pour
tout le monde fin du contrôle continu et
fin de parcours sup méthode que j'ai eu
deux d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur
parce que ça correspond à 10 vocation
paraît-il que nourrir en même temps ce
n'est pas vrai
julie avis que comptez vous proposer
pour améliorer la centale la santé
mentale des jeunes 12 18 ans face aux
données peu joyeux pour déjà la santé
mentale il peut rien le président de la
république qui peut pas par contre qu'on
peut améliorer sait les conditions dans
lesquelles les gens et ça ça peut
contribuer directement à leur bien être
mental
mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont à
voir dans la santé mentale avec l'état
du corps et il est certain qu'une
politique
d'hygiène de vie
qui inclut donc que la lutte contre la
malbouffe 10 qui va avec un impact sur
le mental et ça c'est aussi vieux que le
monde de le savoir par exemple il y en a
une belle formule de spinoza qui dit le
corse un philosophe paru spinoza et dieu
le la pensée ce sera toujours plus que
le corps pensants ok tu avais jamais -
ça veut dire que l'état de votre corps
il pèse directement sur votre état
d'esprit il n'y a pas longtemps des
savants ont trait qu' il y avait un
rapport entre la déprime et l'existence
d'une
dune d'une inflammation permanente un
genre mal de dents surtout tout ce qui
touche à l'estomac et ces choses à bien
pour direct donc premièrement changer
les conditions de vie les conditions de
d'alimentation et puis un troisième
élément bas le coup de main à quoi sert
une situation désastreuse dans un
psychologue scolaire pour vingt ans
trente mille jeunes
pour faire le boulot donc le recrutement
parce que ça permet de s'appuyer sur
quelqu'un qui peut vous aider comme ce
vous sentez vous êtes en train de
fléchir tombée du mauvais côté du cheval
de recevoir une aide qui vous permet de
dominer la situation moi ce que
j'essayerai de faire je dédie ces les
campagnes contre la malbouffe mais c'est
aussi des le fait de garantir des
revenus
à un étudiant une étudiante ça lui
permet de ne pas être tous les mois en
train de se demander comment il veut
boucler la fin du mois comme elle va
payer loyer comment il l'a sauvée alors
qu'on sait plus que maintenant j'ai tenu
la galère général et que l'on garantit
ses revenus
on attend comme on garantit qu alors oui
nous on a prévu dans le programme
d'autonomie une app pardon une
allocation d'autonomie
on a mis à 1063 alors ne demandez pas
pourquoi cela sonne 3 mais je peux vous
dire pourquoi mille parce que c'est le
seuil de pauvreté donc on a dit on peut
être qu'au dessus de quoi ils ont été 5
63 je sais pas alors après on m'a dit à
céline à moi je veux non seulement de
message aux étudiants mais aussi aux
lycéens professionnels
pourquoi pas seulement parce que c'est
mon petit chouchou ce qui est vrai mais
c'est pas une raison purement
personnelle c'est parce que le pays a
incroyablement besoin deux saisons de
gens qui passent des bac pro dans toutes
les professions parce que c'est un
niveau de qualification et à s'élever on
peut croire en bac pro c'est plus
compliqué car en général
bon moi je rétablirai le bac pro à 4 ans
et pour tout le monde 8 63 euros qu'on
soit à la fac ou qu'on soit au lycée pro
d'autant que au lycée pro souvent ya un
décalage d'un an et comme je vais
rétablir le bac pro en quatre ans et pan
3 et encore man 2
bon je sais que la plupart du temps les
jeunes le soir ibos souvent le week end
puis comme si un décalage à peu près un
an par rapport à quelqu'un qui va au bac
tu vas au bac 17 18 ans d'un décalage de
l'entée sur 19 des fois ya deux ans 19
en tout cas déjà 19 tu vas peut avoir un
petit à la maison donc le petit le
boulot et l'école en général ça il ya
quelque chose qui craque donc pour
éviter comme on en arrive là j'ai voulu
que
mais cette allocation aussi au lycée
professionnel et ça va être chaud au bts
voilà
alors si je m'appelle goûté je crois
savoir quelles mesures envisagées vont
aider les industries ainsi bon là ça
dépend vous avez entendu la question
quelle mesure comprend pour aider les
étudiants en difficulté ça dépend
lesquels de difficultés si ses
difficultés en maths tu peux rien pour
vous je suis nul si c'est pour bon j'ai
compris je vous ai compris la blague
aussi donc la difficulté la seule sur
laquelle président une politique a des
moyens d'entrer c'est la difficulté de
sortir de la misère et de pouvoir
étudier je viens de répondre avec une
allocation mais pas seulement c'est
aussi la possibilité de pouvoir accéder
aux arts à la pratique artistique à la
diffusion culturelle et sable ça passe
par différentes facilités qui sont
accordés aux jeunes gens pour qu'ils
puissent le faire y compris le fameux
chèque culture là au début moi j'étais
content ce truc ans encore une attention
accrue montrent consumériste nul te
donne des sous et puis tu vas aller
acheter ce que tu as dit à lui 100 fois
on était plutôt critique mais il est
apparu que
notre affaire et et moi sans que je
compris et ça a bien profité d'abord que
beaucoup de jeunes sont servis et le
plus souvent pour acheter de la lecture
il paraît que là dedans le record c'est
les mangas
voilà on n'a pas à juger moi je sais que
lire s'intéresser à un art quelconque de
toute façon c'est toujours la même
histoire ça vous ouvre l'esprit donc ça
me donne d'autres appétits notre appétit
culturel et moi je crois pas que la
culture soit un supplément d'âme il ya
des gens qui pensent à d'abord toit puis
après si tu as le temps où se cultivent
non on est tous des êtres de culture
vous savez même pas mais la culture est
continuellement en vous à travers la
musique que vous aimez la manière de
vous habiller lego vous avez les
couleurs que vous préférez donc tout ça
c'est le résultat d'une culture
spontanée ou pas d'une culture culture
voilà une culture de culture donc
c'est des sujets qui peuvent pas laisser
indifférent donc on veut s'occuper de
leur pays bon ce tu pas que de
l'économie et du déficit une ligne
arrêtent tous ces trucs le sujet
principal c'est comment on fait pour
mener une vie digne et intéressante
et si possible pour ça pas trop
désagréable et que les autres comme moi
vous abolissez la chasse mais non c'est
pas ça je fais ça ne provoque une émeute
dans ce pays pour rien convaincu
personne de rien et ça sera juste une
bataille rangée non on va par contre où
il ya beau lire certaines chasses déjà
ce qu'on peut qualifier de cruelles
genre la chasse à la glu toi tu aimerais
qu elle mérite fous de la gu là
messieurs c'est pour décoller non pas
d'accord avec ça mais ensuite il ya la
réglementation d'achat se dire plus de
chasse
les week-ends et pendant les vacances
scolaires parce que la prod vient d'être
apportée que c'était
c'était dangereux alors après moi à
titre personnel je ne suis pas chasseur
et j'ai pas l'intention de
devenir mais je connais tellement de
gens que j'aime il songe à seurre que le
premier de leur faire de peine et c'est
pas le sujet le sujet les politiques que
vous m'avez posée la réponse elle est
politique abolir la chasse en général
c'est à mes yeux
impossible donc il faut progresser dans
la compréhension mais pourquoi certaines
chasses en tout cas doivent être
interdites où certains jours de chasse
alors les mesures pour la maltraitance
animale oui ce sera parmi les premières
d'abord la décision clairement énoncé de
fermer les fermes usines différentes
usines je passe continue de paris
comment par exemple comme vous avez
l'élevage nous ont chopé la grippe
aviaire dans le nord cent soixante mille
poules en quoi c'est l'élevage
d'autruches pareillement c'est une
machine alors donc déjà plus de 2 ces
fermes usines belva jeu
concentrationnaire
d'autant que c'est par là que les virus
et transmettre des amis nous aux
sauvages aux animaux domestiques de là à
l'homme c'est aussi mieux qu histoire de
l'humanité mais ce qui est beaucoup plus
récent c'est que comme youtube du plus
en plus de territoire pour y faire des
cultures industrielles de plus en plus
de virus transit ont ce n'est pas le cas
il paraît qu'il y ait encore 1500
réserve tu vois vous va pas finir dans
les pandémies qui ont continué ces
conneries d'élevage intensif à la
démesure pour la maltraitance animale si
oui laquelle je veux dire la première
des choses c'est ça la deuxième c'est
réduire les temps de transport quand on
transporte des bestioles aujourd'hui ces
26 heures faut les faire depuis le 26 et
puis l'interdiction formelle immédiate
dès le mois de mai tant pis pour ceux
qui se font prendre là dedans ils
étaient 10 2
du broyage des animaux vivants bon
c'était prévu qu'au 1er janvier
s'arrêter au 1er janvier s'est rien
passé du tout et la fin du mois de
janvier monsieur m'a comment faire un
décret dans lequel il dit que ça va
pouvoir continuer jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 ben moi je suis pas
d'accord de quoi je parle du broyage des
des poussins mâles ils sont 3 500 mis 50
millions par an vous avez bien entendu
50 millions de bestioles vivante
les poussins laborieuse direct pourquoi
parce qu'on ne sait pas les repérer à
bhl et que ben avec un petit coq vous
faites pas une poule pondeuse et comme
c'est du boulot mon dieu ce qui les
intéresse voit la même chose avec 20
millions de petites cannes
oiseaux en voilà et tout ça faut le
prendre très au sérieux parce que vous
devez savoir que 80 % des volailles
vivantes des oiseaux vivants sont des
oiseaux d'élevage de l'irda volaille
et
bonjour pensez vous réellement
convertissant tout notre agriculture bio
on réussir à nous même bien nourrir les
autres pays bas oui d'abord on ne
devrait même pas avoir besoin de dix
agriculture bio c'est l'agriculture
normalement c'est bio mais a fini par
trouver normal ça sonne agriculture
chimique ou déversent des tonnes et des
tonnes de pesticides donc arrêter ça
aujourd'hui dans 90% des urines des
êtres humains en france il ya des traces
de pesticides mais ça c'est même pas le
pire les petits
ça c'est le pesticide connu le
glyphosate mais ledit faisable quand il
est en nature que la flotte au dessus se
décompose en petits morceaux et les
petits morceaux et se combine avec
d'autres trucs et c'est pire car c'est
encore pire qu'il diffusera donc moi
j'ai tendre et le champ de recherche
la recherche physique avoue cherche
quelqu'un dans la terre pour savoir où
on en est et quel genre de poison du
genre absorbé vous verrez que l'on va
découvrir que des tas de maladies ont
une origine comme on s'en doute
aujourd'hui de plus en plus
environnementale liée à la consommation
de pesticides de consommation
involontaire aucun d'entre vous a jamais
demandé à bouffer du plastique ou du
glyphosate
l'attend est ce que j'ai répondu à la
question est ce qu'on va y arriver par
le rire et pourquoi pas ce qu'il faut
c'est aussi bête que ça et sinon qu'est
ce qu'on fait on mange pas bon si on va
manger donc il faut développer
l'agriculture vivrière pour ça faut
qu'il y ait des paysans il nous en
manque trois cent mille la même moitié
des paysans affiché pendant les 12
années qui viennent à la retraite
aujourd'hui surmortalité des paysans qui
considérable puisqu'il se pend un paysan
gilles pour 1000 celui-ci dans tous les
jours ou tous les deux jours je me
rappelle pas exactement la statistique
me l'épouvantable donc c'est alors il ya
deux choses à dire il n'y a pas assez de
paysans 2 ceux qui font un boulot a pas
l'air de s'en trouver si bien et royan
faut davantage parce que pour faire de
l'agriculture bio dans tout pays faut
300 mille paysans falloir proposer notre
manière de vivre d'autres manières
d'être payés faut qu'ils aient des
revenus de soit garanti c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je
mettrais des pipes des prix plancher est
une obligation de la nourriture bio pour
toutes les cantines de gamins donc avec
ça tu faire marcher donc fait du remue
jeudi qui 97 bonjour taxerait vous les
pollueurs payant
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya une
question qui est sur le nucléaire soit
juste avant
assistant est pas mal
bonjour monsieur êtes vous prêt à mettre
100 centrales nucléaires pour produire
de l'énergie avec des procédés plus
écologique et plus propre oui c'est
absolument ma position et je voudrais
bien qu'on me comprenne moi j'ai pas de
baston idéologique avec le nucléaire
serait il un ferry de loïc sait que
c'est dangereux alors maintenant je vois
le chien a plein qui oblige fukushima
coogi giambi oublier three mile island
et qui pensent que non il y aura jamais
d'accident mais même l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire même tous les gens qui
s'occupent du nucléaire dit ça ça
n'existe pas et n'a jamais existé une
certitude à 100% n'existe pas dans la
nature ni dans la réalité donc par la
force des choses et d'ailleurs des
incidents il a continuellement dans le
pays ce qu'il ya c'est que c'est un
incident qui jusque là ont toujours été
jugulée mais un jour rin le rhin qui
sera pas à juguler et dans ce cas là
même si c'est 0,01 la probabilité est
bien c'est 100% de dégâts derrière et
comme je dis dégâts faut vous comprends
bien de quoi je parle on est on est un
petit pays malgré tout la surface la
centrale de nogent ciel à un problème
faute des ménages et 12 millions de
personnes personne n'est capable de
faire ça ça veut dire qu'il y aura un
maximum de gens qui feront qu'en ce
moment une pagaille est incroyable et
puis un maximum aussi qu'ils resteront
tout simplement parce qu'ils espèrent
ils savent pas où aller ailleurs donc je
demande qu'on prenne avec beaucoup de
sérieux ça c'est pas une discussion
entre les vertueux qui veulent une
énergie décarbonée et puis les autres
qui seraient des doux rêveurs les gens
que moi parce qu'il propose de procéder
autrement est parfaitement capable de
produire autrement de l'énergie bon
faudra mettre les bouchées douvres à
retrousser les manches des chemises bâle
fera sinon quoi qu'est-ce qui est prêt à
donner son nom son adresse et son numéro
de téléphone est il écrit jamais il y
aura un problème et si jamais il y en a
appelé moi d'accord voilà vous si vous
voulez pas moi et je pense que ce serait
pas ça elle le faire
tall serez-vous les pollueurs payant
j'en déduis que c'est rendrez-vous
payant la pollution dans leur pays oui
bien sûr principe de base je suis qui
dégueulasse toupet la réparation toi
et il sa bouge plus
j'aimerais savoir quel est votre plan
pour lutter contre les violences
sexuelles laisse
moi je propose que dans ce domaine on
prenne ce que les associations mm ont
proposé parce qu'ils y ont réfléchi donc
discuter c'est des sujets qui sont ou
pas simple donc lé les ont demandé que
l'on met un plan
dont l oms et manuela les associations
féminines et féministes
elles ont évalué sa 1 milliards en
prenant en compte toutes les
conséquences de la violence sexiste
sexuelle jusqu au féminicide d'accord
donc on pose qu'on reprenne leurs plans
à quoi inventer un autre s'il en existe
déjà un fait par des gens qui
connaissent quelque chose voilà moi par
contre l'un des problèmes que je
soulèverai pour lesquelles j'ai besoin
des chercheurs en sciences sociales et
des chercheurs en sciences et
pédagogique c'est pour arriver à
analyser pourquoi un homme peut se
comporter comme ça parce que ça souvent
cédé interdit très lourd qui sont à
l'oeuvre et une affaire d'éducation
des garçons qui vont quand vous avez
pour vous donner une idée de la mauvaise
éducation
c'est comme vous avez un gars comme
zemmour qui dit que les femmes sont le
butin de l'homme un bon il manque quand
on part d'une idée pareille le résultat
il peut être désastreux si le butin est
pas d'accord bon
mais au delà de cet exemple qui est
caricatural il ya plein d'autres choses
comme ça qui autorise les hommes des
comportements qui s'avère en fait pas
acceptable 1 dans l'éducation de nos
gars sont donc là il ya quelque chose à
revoir de a jusqu'à z et pour ça on a
besoin des chargements si on sent
vraiment une question justement aussi
quand on parle de violences sexistes et
sexuelles hors série rue du harcèlement
de rue aujourd'hui comment on arrive à
lutter plus efficacement il n'en sait
pas aujourd'hui qui
je sais pas parce que
c'est vrai donc c'est pas une invention
de
si je mets de côté les questions
d'éducation qu'après tout ferait pas de
mal
des campagnes nationales pour
ridiculiser le comportement des
harceleurs je pense que c'est sans doute
qu'on aura de plus efficace parce qu'on
a parlé de verbaliser alors là je me dis
pas non consommer parce que
qui est ce qu'il va verbaliser le
policier qui devient d'un seul coup
celui qui constate l'infraction et qui
vous inflige la peine donc chaque
policier transformant jugé ingérable
entre une taille de ce qu'on m'a dit on
dira pas comment on fait un truc paille
donc je préfère dire que la question est
ouverte moi je sais que
j'opterai pour des campagnes
publiques de ridiculisation de du
harceleur
jusqu'à ce que ça devienne un
comportement qui rend nom de la personne
devant elle même c'est comme ça que l'on
s'impose des règles mal c'est quand on
viole des règles morales qu'on s'est
donné on sent mal justement c'est ça
qu'il faut faire c'est que le nombre
viennent à se sentir mal quand on a ce
comportement en gros c'est prévention
éducation et la réalisation plutôt
prévention éducation verbalisation jeu
pas comment on fait mais je préfère le
dire que c'est la facilité de dire ouais
y'a qu'à verbaliser ok tu sais comment
on sait rien ou alors tu vas donner un
pouvoir plus à un policier qui va être
ton juge bon il raffole de ça je vous
préviens parce que par exemple le délit
qui est le plus intéressant pour un
policier celui d' outrage c'est pourquoi
c'est parce que le policier est l katia
outrage bien il sait qui c'est qu'a
outrage élan face de lui et donc qui
fait à la fois le constat et puis marque
un point toc nikos une colonne et david
a marqué un point
alors l'endométriose
je vous le sachiez en a décidé un autre
groupe parlementaire a soumis deux
déposé un projet de résolution à
l'assemblée nationale et c'est et
clémentine autant qui le défendent est
pour mon groupe est la bonne surprise
c'est comme a été majoritaire ça ne
m'arrive pas souvent et donc la
résolution a été adoptée mais cette
résolution qu'est ce qu'elle disait
qu'il fallait placer l'endométriose le
reconnaître comme une maladie de longue
durée
est comme ça ça donne lieu à
indemnisation des soins et indemnisation
du jour et on n'est pas capable de
travailler parce qu'on souffre trop
alors pour que tout le monde est à
commencer par les garçons
comprennent de quoi il s'agit il s'agit
de règles qui sont particulièrement
douloureuse pour les filles parce que
c'est un processus bizarre qui fait que
c'est comme s'il y avait des petits
granules sûr à l'intérieur
qui se colle et qui enfin qui se colle
qui apparaissent et qui souvent se
répandre dans le reste du corps a plus à
voir c'est pour c'est une maladie qui a
une exposition la mortalité aux
alentours de 35 ans n'est pas
négligeable mais pendant
la commune temps c'était considéré pas
considéré comme une maladie et pas le
caractère incapacitant de l'endométriose
n'étaient pas reconnus et les filles aux
est pas en parler puis quand l on parle
et on leur dit ouais tu t'écoutes trop
c'est normal d'avoir un peu maltais
douillette tout ça est bref c'était
relégué et le les adultes pour les plus
jeunes femmes mais les médecins mais bon
vous comportez vous faut dire les choses
comme elles sont pas correctement parce
que bon c'est complètement incapacitant
dans certains cas l'endométriose tu peux
rien faire d'autre tellement tu as mal
et puis bon le la le réconfort il vient
de la piqûre de morphine d'un truc comme
ça à petite dose d'accord mais c'est pas
spécialement bon pour pour la santé cds
jour tu peux pas aller bosser c'est
aussi simple que ça donc moi je suis
pour qu'on inscrive dans le tableau des
maladies de longue durée de manière à ce
qu'on puisse faire face comme ça et puis
que la recherche avance quoi qu'on nous
mette plus de monde pour régler
ce problème moi je pense j'en sais rien
je pas médecin mais je pense que comme
le nombre de cas qui ont été repérés et
conciliable semapa une femme sur dix ça
doit avoir un rapport moi je dis vous
dis ça comme ça sans aucune autorité
scientifique avec des éléments qui sont
ils souhaitent à la nourriture soit à
l'environnement voilà en tout cas la
réponse je les données
alors qu'anne k mddep allez vous
allonger le congé maternité qui est trop
courts cette semaine à répartir sauf que
l'om est recommande six mois
d'allaitement et faire garder un bébé de
dix à douze semaines c'est trop rapide
font alors la position que moi je tiens
c'est d'abord il faut que les deux
le garçon à fille ou les deux parents si
ses deux filles ou si ces deux garçons
ont le même le même temps
de congé et qu'ils le prennent en même
temps pour s'occuper du gamin alors le
problème de l'allaitement bon c'est une
recommandation
mais sans plus et ou non n'est pas
d'accord là dessus sur ce qu'il ya lieu
de faire est-ce qu'il faut se la poser
une pas bon donc pour moi ce n'est pas
le critère le critère c'est le temps
d'accueil du jeune gamin parce que le
temps d'accueil c'est en tant pour les
parents parce que figure toi que quand
il y en a un qui atteint gamins car y
voilà c'est ali révolutionnaire c'est
plus le même tu as le jour avant elle
jours après sa strictement plus rien à
voir c'est tu commences une autre vie
donc d'abord il s'agit de l'accueillir
le gamin s'en occuper et prendre ses
marques avec et puis il s'agit pour les
prendre aussi de découvrir le truc et
s'adapter voilà donc on était nous on
était parti sur le même temps dix
semaines après la naissance parce qu'il
ya des congés qui sont avant et que moi
je demande aux filles de prendre parce
que ces congés il faut pas faire le la
brave
si on les a imaginés c'est parce que
c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux pour la santé
de la maman comme du gamin et puis après
il ya dix semaines avec les deux parents
qui sont de type est bon faut vivre avec
son temps les amis c'est moi je vous dis
c'est que c'est un dieu bon c'est quoi
vivre avec son temps j'ai connu une
période où vous permettez pas qu'il se
soit de dire qu'il en avait marre à sa
sauce des produits atteindre votre petit
à la marque pas en quoi un mauvais père
mauvais mère tu vois bon la vérité c'est
que tu parles avec n'importe qui
aujourd'hui la parole est plus libre
mais c'est les filles des premières qui
dimanche j'en peux plus je vois pas
pourquoi je dois rester bouclé pendant
huit semaines dix semaines avec le bon
d'accord c'est on veut à ce qu'il aime
beaucoup et thomas c'est impressionnant
comme l'existence à donner à manger puis
nettoyer les fesses et puis discuté un
peu quelqu'un qui répond pas et ça
pendant des semaines pendant ce temps
thon rouge juin il va y bien et anti
sort et tu as l'impression que tu est
coupé de la vie tout simplement alors
bon les délais je viens de donner voilà
c'est bien après ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'il ya des crèches et puis des écoles
maternelles qui accueillent les gamins
bon voilà alors je vais vous dire une
phrase horrible plus un gosse et
socialiser tôt plus il est ouvert et
confiant alors socialiser un jour
j'étais je ne lui ai jamais dit ça il y
avait un gars de doigté pour composer
mon truc qui quoi où vous voulez leur
bourrer le crâne dès l'enfance 1000 r il
est compris voulu leur apprendre le
socialisme non c'est pas de ça dont je
parle c'est que un petit être humain il
a besoin d'être pris dans un contexte
largement pas toujours ça avant
tu te trimballes ecc ton gamin sur toi
et puis c'était en famille et pour le
monde tout ça c'est plutôt aujourd'hui
ok voilà voilà ma réponse allez on y va
[Musique]
bon alors c'est sûr qu'il faut le faire
on a les profs les plus mal payés
d'europe on a une crise de vocations
gigantesque qui a 30 % moins de
candidats pour faire preuve qu' il y en
a eu
autrefois il ya un mal vivre qui est
généralisé avec aussi une prise de
suicide sur laquelle moi je veux pas
trop rentrer mais quand il ya une
réalité alors ça peut pas durer comme ça
les profs ils ont perdu aux alentours
d'un d'un mois de salaire
avec un blocage de dix ans de leur
indice d'accord donc premières choses
ont établi lundi 15 points de plus ça
vous amène en début de carrière à 2000
euros
fo se rend compte que c'est pas volé en
2000 euros pour un prof qui commence il
ya qu à vous dire que un prof c'est bac
+ 5 normalement
un capitaine de police et bac + 3 on
sait de boulot qualifier mais il n'y a
pas de raison qu'il ya un écart
aujourd'hui le prof qui commence et 1800
euros dès fois moins et puis le
capitaine de police qui commence et 2400
ya rien qui justifie un écart pareil
dans la qualification donc voilà ma
réponse un rattrapage du point d'indicé
et de redéfinition de grilles de
salaires pour
procéder à une nouvelle augmentation
qu'on négocie et aussi surtout de
nouvelles conditions d'enseignement
bonjour monsieur mélenchon c'est une
question pour vous ce volet savoir si au
final ne serait pas plus intéressant de
baisser le coût de la vie plutôt que
d'augmenter forcément les salaires
puisque drastiquement ça devrait faire
augmenter
toutes les productions
qui sont faites dans le pays est-ce
qu'il ne vaudrait pas mieux au final
baisser les loyers baisser le coût des
matières premières
plutôt que d'augmenter les salaires
alors bon c'est la bonne question
évidemment qu'il vaudrait mieux baisser
le prix des choses que
d'augmenter les salaires parce que
l'augmentation de salaire va développer
la consommation populaire justement des
gens comme moi compte là dessus c'est à
dire développer la consommation
populaire ses 53 % du pib delà du pays
si on me développe ça ça veut dire qu'il
ya de l'activité et qu'il ya de
l'activité il ya de l'emploi etc avec le
monde en profite donc mais en même temps
il ya une limite et vous avez raison
c'est de dire que ben ça ça pousse au
productivisme comme on dit à produire
tout le plus toujours plus toujours plus
donc il ya un compromis maintenant voit
pas le tour et surtout les matières
premières qu'on le veuille ou non elles
ne sont l'objet de tarifs sur le marché
mondial pour d'autres choses non on peut
en effet vous avez raison par exemple
baisser le prix des transports baisser
le prix de l'énergie baisser le prix de
la nourriture ça c'est des choses
possibles parce que la nourriture n est
pas à son prix de revient aujourd'hui
elle est à son prix de production plus
un coefficient multiplicateur qui
appliquées par les grandes surfaces donc
moi je compte jouer des deux baisser les
prix c'est à dire baisser les coûts des
services publics et augmenter les
salaires de manière les gens puissent
respirer si je devais compter que sur la
baisse du prix des choses ça prend mais
infiniment plus de temps et dans le
passé ça a eu des résultats pervers par
exemple la nourriture au tour fin
c'était 20 % du budget de la famille eux
il ya longtemps et pendant les années
soixante soixante dix on a fait tomber
sa à 9% et donc 11 points pouvoir
l'achat de gagner mais sur le dos de qui
des paysans parce qu'ils n'ont pas été
mieux pays après ils ont été moins payés
donc vous voyez il faut tout ça ça se
manier avec le précaution là où vous
avez où je donne raison c'est que oui il
faut aussi penser à la baisse des prix à
la baisse des prix c'est lié à
l'amélioration des machines qui sont
mises en service et la réduction des
coûts de production l'inflation selon
les prix de l'essence le prix des
matières premières vous qu'est ce que
vous faites par rapport à ça et aussi
confiant que je fais c'est
le bloc les prix de première nécessité
alors il ya dedans les carburants la
nourriture de première nécessité et puis
peut y avoir d'autres produits jo va
prendre le modèle comme modèle ski
comment ils font dormir de la réunion où
il ya en effet une codification des prix
est bon pour que ça marche bien plus tôt
que ce soit seulement le préfet qui
décide ils ont institué des commissions
de citoyens qui donnent leur avis sur
quels sont les produits qui doivent
rentrer dans les listes de produits de
première nécessité ça change suivant les
périodes de l'année d'accord donc c'est
ce sens de l'accueil que je compte mu
blocage des prix ça c'est une
indispensable maison est un peu plus là
donc peut trouver une solution monsieur
mélenchon que comptez vous faire pour
ont topé les communes rurales et et
créer de l'emploi bon bah ça se tient
parce que s'il ya de l'emploi en europe
si on recopiait de l'emploi donc il faut
aider les gens à aller y habiter il faut
le leur proposer puis une fois qu'on a
un bilan déjà on fait ce qu'il faut ou
une petite ville pour éviter qu'elle se
vide de son sang par exemple il ya plus
de tirs est depuis de prendre dessous
bon tu veux pas aller au marché local si
tapie laisse ou s'ils n'ont pas la carte
vont mettre plus de direct autre exemple
plus de postes bon ou si tu veux que le
facteur passe chez toi et qu' il reste
juste pour que tu es le temps de lui
poser de questions tu paye pour ça c'est
honteux mais ça ça existe c'est comme ça
que ça marche aujourd'hui donc faut
arrêter de faire disparaître les
services publics alors ça veut dire par
exemple il se ferme tous les jours une
pause depuis dix ans
depuis dix ans il se remet tous les
jours une école dans p on arrête tout ça
voilà ce que je compte faire partir vous
pouvez lui beau gosse les avoir sur
place à l'école primaire oui bien que ça
choquerait vie complètement partir de
non vous avez des services publics vous
pouvez vivre localement donc les deux
vont ensemble puis après vous verrez
parce que bientôt vous allez vous
apercevoir d'un problème quand on vous
parle pas de trop parce que pour
l'instant vous écouter tous les bêtises
qui m'aurait bien madame le pen c'est
qu'il ya un problème dans ce pays c'est
que la moyenne c'est 1,9 enfant par
femme bon on ne sait pas à quoi
ressemble un enfant 09 mais ce dont on
est sûr c'est que ça ça permet pas de
reproduire la population donc la
population elle va décroître et si la
population décroît tous les croix y
compris l'activité il ya des pays en
europe qui ont déjà franchi le seuil par
exemple en hongrie ils sont 1,4 donc ils
se remettront pas sauf à faire venir du
monde alors disent les xénophobes
justement il ya une question sur un
terme qui sont revenus dans cette
campagne qui est utilisé par exemple
mais aussi par vale petras dernièrement
grands emplacements south east quoi
comme réaction c'est stupide ça ne veut
rien dire parce que tu remplaces qui
part qui s'est pas des terriens par des
martiens des gens viennent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas pu rester là au médiateur pour
un média où ils sont mais ils sont mieux
hein je n'ai jamais demandé à partir
ils partent parce que il n'ya pas
d'avenir il n'y a pas de vie qu'ils
arrivent et ils sont maltraités mais
qu'est ce qui se passe une fois qu'ils
arrivent mort visant la population alors
des fois ils amènent des plats qu'on
connaissait pas on fait les mêmes il
amène des musiques des rythmes on peut
des foyers même pas besoin de ça il
suffit de regarder la télé et ça c'est
important ça s'appelle la créolisation
alors c'est un mot qui fait peur
dit se mêlant sont mécontents du
remplacement je pas dit content ni pas
content c'est un fait de paul finale en
1950 chaque français y en avait un sur
dix câble et un grand père étranger
aujourd'hui c'est ans sur quatre voilà
c'est tout donc ça se fait tout seul
c'est la créolisation le mélange on
parle tous la même langue france bon je
vois qui eux qui disent des bêtises
propos d'aidé
peur de travailler chez eux mais c'est
vous chez eux la bulle humanise n'existe
pas et des français musulmans d'autres
catholiques de vue puissent aux français
donc faut arrêter d'embêter les gens
avec la religion et de servir de tous
les prétextes pour se payer leur
emplacement ça existe pas ce qui existe
c'est la vie voilà l avis toujours la
plus forte
toque à temps vous critiquez beaucoup
des riches êtes vous d'accord et
collants quand il dit qu'on est riche
quand on touche plus de 4000 euros par
mois
et quel est votre salaire tout le mandat
confondues alors déjà pour confirmer
mandat c'est pas possible parce que j'en
ai quand et je fume plus depuis la salle
blague là mon salaire et des pains
salaires c'est un une indemnité c'est
important parce que sinon à pourny et
l'âge de la retraite pourquoi vous y
êtes pas bien parce que moi j'ai le
choix je peux choisir de rester ou de
partir
un travailleur il peut pas il est obligé
de rester jusqu'à ce qu'il ait son
indemnité la mienne est de 4000 euros
par mois ce qui est la paye dans cadre
du bon niveau voilà et pour ces 4000
euros je bosse à ma façon c'est à dire
que mon idée est que le mandat d'un élu
et un mandat politique dont je fais de
la politique toute ma vie tous les jours
voilà je ne m'en plains pas j'ai choisi
quand j'aurai pu faire autre chose profs
ou peut-être journalistes j'ai choisi de
mener une bataille politique
je suis indemnisés pour le faire après
ce que je suis d'accord pour dire que
quand on touche plus de 4000 euros par
mois on est riche mon drame c'est une
discussion sur le mot moi ce que je sais
c'est qu'avec le système d'un projet
imaginé avec mes amis tout ce qui est en
dessous de 4000 euros par tête de pipe
tu perds moins tout ce qui est au dessus
du pair à puce voilà d'impôts bien sûr
donc on va au lieu d'avoir cinq tranches
qui fait porter tous par le milieu on en
aura 14 comme c'était le cas avant et à
la dernière on apprend vraiment beaucoup
jusqu'à 90% mais c'est pas une mesure
communiste et il mesure qui a commencé
aux états unis d'amérique voilà vous
critiquez beaucoup les riches mais non
mais on sait pas compris masse critique
pas les riches je critique et la
mécanique dans les schismes ans comment
ça marche et me faites pas dire
des choses que j'ai pas envie de venir
mais c'est pas très malin de penser que
j'ai déjà entendu ça les gens diras tu
comprends moi aussi je suis c'est pas
qu'ils aient des risques qui m'ennuie
c'est qu'il ya des poèmes balles hautes
pas compris car pour contrôler 2,6 à
dépôt c'est parce qu'il ya des riches
s'il ya des riches c'est parce qu'il ya
des pauvres c'est-à-dire
l'appauvrissement des 1 provoque la
richesse des autres victor hugo disait
l'enfer des riches le maire pendant le
paradis des riches effet de l'enfer des
pauvres alors après chômage +1 c1
c'est ok je sais pas ce qu'il est bon
alors leur seul au carnet lequel sera le
salaire des députés des ministres en
6ème république alors déjà c'est pas un
salaire c'est une indemnité pour la
raison que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
lors ne me dites pas c'est du pinaillage
non parce que par exemple si vous êtes
apprentis vous savez comment vous êtes
code du travail dont vous n'êtes pas
content tu es chômeurs n'est pas content
et étudiants
et oui bon donc une indemnité c'est pas
un salaire alors quel sera-t-il lorsque
pas réfléchi en tout cas à mon avis
qu'on soit ministre ou qu'on soit député
il faut pouvoir vivre bien d'abord parce
que ça permet de vivre et donc il faut
les revenus qui vont avec a prédit
qu'elle veut de brûlon pour décider pas
moi parce que moi je ne leur ai pas de
ça
non pas sur des sujets plutôt de société
jeux console est ok
journée c'est
sympa merci pour les veufs votre
campagne
oui alors l'euthanasie je préfère
content de ma chute on s'est engueulés
sur le mot à utiliser même en a fait
déposer une proposition de loi à
l'assemblée nationale
dont le chef de file et et carl une fiat
moi j'ai pas peur du mot suicide assisté
parce que sur le plan des idées
c'est une très vieille idée qui date des
stoïciens c'est un courant philosophique
que la saint glinglin de l'antiquité et
pourquoi pas ce que ça dit au fond
je ne suis vraiment libre donc vraiment
un être humain que si j'ai la
possibilité lorsque quelque chose m'est
insupportable de me soustraire donc il
distinguer ce qu'on ne compte rien et ce
contrecoup auront peu des choses si on
peut quelque chose on fait si on peut
rien là deux solutions à on supporte
deux ne supporte pas mais en reste libre
parce qu'on a la possibilité d'étendre
la lumière je suis content c'est moi qui
trouvais l'expression hilton da et la
chanteuse juliette on a fait une chanson
qui est magnifique donc oui je suis pour
le suicide assisté je pense que c'est
une liberté fondamentale la pleine
disposition de soi il dessine pour soir
on est propriétaire de soi et c'est
exactement la même chose que de dire
qu'on est pour l'interruption volontaire
de l'eau c'est ce qui revient à dire que
les femmes sont propriétaires de leur
propre corps à l'exclusion de toute
autre personne c'est-à-dire leurs
enfants leurs parents leurs époux sont
propriétaires de même et être
propriétaire de soi c'est pas le mot
propriétaire qu'il faut retenir c'est le
mot m et donc on n'a pas d'autres
maîtres que soi même ça c'est le nec
plus ultra de l'émancipation donc non
seulement je suis pour le suicide
assisté je suppose qu'il soit inscrit
dans la constitution comme liv et g où
la liberté de choix du genre parce que
c'est sa partenaire soi même et ne
dépend de personne d'autre que de
soi-même pour quelque chose car un
rapport aux rapports avec soi même et à
l'intimé
si vous êtes élu président quels sont
vos projets à maintien de handicap et
notamment celui ci a
alors d'abord sur le handicap d'une
manière générale moi je vois sur la
vieille ligne c du port scion tout gamin
c'est l'inclusion c'est à dire on fait
tout ce qu'on peut pour que tous les
gosses aient une vie de gosse avec
d'autres gosses qui au passage
apprennent bien que ya des gamins qui
peuvent souffrir de tel ou tel handicap
et que cet handicap va être un cap
moteur au mental mais ça ne réduit pas
sa dignité d'être humain ni son intérêt
d'être humain ok donc ça c'est pour
l'école quant aux adultes ma position
la suivante je suis pour que les
personnes en situation de handicap
puissent avoir une vie autonome dont il
accède au travail on en prend des
dispositions pour ça que leurs salaires
leurs revenus soient des sens et en
particulier je suis pour que ont
renoncé à cette idée sur le tout assez
horribles qu'a inventé lama la majorité
qui est de dire que l'on vous donne
votre allocation d'adulte handicapé
mais que si vous êtes en couple on tient
compte des revenus des deux noms moi je
suis pour que la location soit
individuelle et inconditionnelle et
après bon alors ça s'appelle la dea
conjugale isation de l'aide
à la personne handicapée quant à
l'autisme là on est dans un problème qu
un casse tête pourquoi c'est un casse
tête parce que déjà pour
identifier les causes un personne est
d'accord est ce qu'elles sont
psychologiques est ce qu'elles sont
physiques pour identifier les remèdes
personne n'est d'accord est-ce que ça
doit être un comportement un
comportementaliste
ou est-ce que ça doit être pied bref
c'est extrêmement bouyer ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'ils existent et voir de soins
de traitement et que de toute façon il
ya un devoir d'accueil qui est plus
spécifique pour les autistes que pour
d'abord pour les aider à vivre une vie
normale et ensuite pour leur permettre
de faire face à la situation
quand les parents n'y sont plus donc moi
je suis pour la prise en charge par la
société du handicap avec clarté netteté
et qu'on y met les moyens dont on a
besoin parce que je ne sais pas ce que
pourrait vouloir dire dans ce domaine
une limite aux moyens qu'est-ce que ça
peut bien vouloir dire bon c'est comme
une limite aux soins laquelle non il
faut donner autant qu'il est nécessaire
et il faut cotiser soi même chacun selon
ses
rien voilà
pour moi j'ai d'abord on commence par
dire qu'il y en a parce que je ne fais
pas mon genre de dire bon annonce était
absolument impossible de cacher qu'il en
aille qu'elles sont insupportables moi
je le dis j'ai évidemment beaucoup fait
de reproches après vous savez comment
c'est au finish caricature si tu
critiques s'étaient anti-flics whip
anti-flics moi pourquoi je renty flic
n'est pas de société qu'ils aient
fonctionné sans
d'une police mais police
c'est un temps du maintien de l'ordre
les forces de l'ordre qu'on parle pas du
tout but le but c est de gardiens de la
paix regardez la tranquillité à
l'oreille à la répression du crime un
bref et sérieusement déjà on fait une
police où il ya plus d officiers de
police judiciaire que demande de la bac
qui sont d'ailleurs dissoute parce que
la bac à mes yeux c'est pas la bonne
manière d'organiser la police de terrain
la police de terrain doit être organisée
comme une police de proximité et il faut
donc plus de gens dans la police
judiciaire qui mène la bataille pour
affronter les source de profond de la
délinquance dire le trafic de drogue le
trafic d'êtres humains et le trafic
d'armes sont nés trois gros trafics
auxquels on a affaire fasse ainsi que le
vol en réunion qui est la fraude fiscale
de ceux qui osent ils leur argent le
cache ici le cache là bas
tous les plans il ya des réponses
différentes la police de proximité
elle a pas besoin d'un déploiement d'une
armada n'est non plus de la mentalité de
cowboy que nokia donc moi ma position
c'est que d'abord les violences
du passé doivent être punis qui aura pas
de prescription c'est à dire que ce
qu'ils ont et borny et sciemment et
froidement 32 personnes doivent être
identifiés
et punis parce que c'est interdit de le
faire et surtout redressé c'est à dire
venu psychologiquement à la
compréhension du fait que tirer un coup
de fusil en pleine figure de quelqu'un
pour les borniers passait pas par hasard
que 32 personnes ont été bannies éborgné
et que d'entendre pays du monde les
borgnes mans a l'air de faire partie des
méthodes de répression donc tout ça ça
veut dire quelque chose qui tourne plus
rond dans la tête parce que tu vois le
genre de gars qui décident de temps rien
ça dans les figures ou une grenade de
désencerclement ou de menacer des
milliers de gens sur une place pour les
tabasser à la sortie donc il ya la
refonte de la police pour en faire une
police entièrement républicaine et une
police estime est respectée par la
population il ya donc des choses
disparaitront les flash ball les
grenades de désencerclement les
techniques de massage
la bac et puis demant les braves n'en
parlons pas qu une invention on avait
annulé les bras c'était comme ça qui
avait été tué malik oussékine c'est ce
que sont les braves ces deux là qui
monte sur une moto qui en a un qui
tabassent et jean mon passage ça a pas
possible c'est d'une violence absolue
c'est une brutalité qui tombera donc une
police plus tranquille et puis pour les
manifs le désarmement des policiers
voilà quant aux autres ils savent que se
servir d'une arme ceux qui sont sérieux
c'est une chose trop sérieuse pour être
comme ça galvaudé voila voila ma vision
de ce que le cac a pris à des méthodes
que je peux plus accepter quoi le le
contrôle au faciès ça va croire ya plein
de gens et mounis boîte exagère
forcément les contrôles jamais donc ils
se rendent pas compte de ce que c'est
d'être contrôlé trois fois quatre fois
que cinq fois par jour juste parce que
des tas les cheveux crépus ou que tu es
un peu basané ou je sais pas quoi sur
des critères d'identification physiques
qui sont des purs préjuger de la part de
ceux qui font les interpellations et le
reste voilà alors igor popov 72
êtes-vous patriotes oui alors pourquoi
vous ce s'entendre parce que après si
c'est pour faire
nationaliste c'est pas la même chose et
man d'ailleurs comment le vocabulaire a
évolué dans l'histoire faut que vous
savez ça chez sur la colline de valmy
tous m'ont crié vive la nation mais il
parlait pas la même langue est parlée
même dieu et ce n'est pas du même coin à
l'époque ça voulait dire la nation
c'était pas le royaume et si c'est pas
le royaume tpr est sujette et citoyens
et le mot nation qui était de gauche est
passée de là vers les conservateurs et
après les autres parler de la patrie ok
donc
la patrie ça voulait dire la terre de
nos pères bon pourra dire nos pères et
mères mais c'est ça que ça voulait dire
nous sommes tous les enfants d'un même
endroit
et donc
par extension on est passé de l'endroit
où on vit tous à la communauté légale
c'est-à-dire la loi qui s'applique à
tous parce qu'on a tous décidé ensemble
donc en ce sens oui je suis patriote
j'aime mon pays
j'aime ça va quand même sa culture mais
c'est pas ça qui fait de moi en français
ce qui fait de moi un français c'est la
carte d'identité ce qui fait de moi un
patriote c'est alors on dit la
différence c'est le patriotisme c'est
l'amour dit 'tiens bluetooth et est pas
et le nationalisme c'est la haine des
autres c'est un peu sommaire mais bon
comme il faut bien trouver une
distinction entre les mots en voilà un
patriote c'est justement pas détester
les autres quand on est français
pourquoi parce qu'un français il a une
devise politique liberté égalité
fraternité et que ça s'applique à tous
les êtres humains tout le monde sans
exception hommes femmes quelle que soit
la religion etc etc voilà comment et
pourquoi je suis patriote alors après
bon des fois j'exagère je coupe tout le
monde c'est à dire que j'aime vraiment
très beau coup pays des fois et
peut-être ça me conduit à dire des
bêtises à propos des autres alors en
réponse les thèmes de l'insécurité de
vandalisme et les vols à une violence
sont inexistants dans votre rhétorique y
sont bien réelles dans notre quotidien
pourquoi
ne sais pas où vous voyez ça n'en parle
mais la proportion de des questions
qu'on pose si on ne pose pas je réponds
pas
par contre y en a qui passent leur temps
à ça et puis qu'ils veulent que tout le
monde ne parle que de ça bon
l'insécurité et le vandalisme c'est pas
pareil bien d'accord le vandalisme se
tient à l'incivilité
l'insécurité s'adresse soit à des
personnes soit des biens
c'est pas pareil de prendre couteau de
se faire piquer sa mobylette c'est pas
pareil approprient du vandalisme
quelqu'un qui veut qu'à st je sais pas
quoi hein quoi je suis pas d'accord
après il ya les vols avec violence sont
inexistants dans votre rhétorique mans
où il ya des vols avec violence et c'est
pas bien qu'est ce que les gens disent
de plus je viens d'expliquer quels
genres de police je défends mais je
comprends pas que je comprends pas le
sens de la question ils sont bien réels
dans notre quotidien parce que dans
votre quotidien sais qui vous êtes qui
votre quotidien de quoi vous êtes riche
et vos habitant un quartier luxueux vous
n'aimez pas que l'on vandalisent autres
porsche et on vous a volé votre tableau
de maître chez chaque volume dire non
oui c'est certain certains commentaires
qui disaient bas comme quoi oui à la
france insoumise jean luc mélenchon
quand on parle d'insécurité il a
tendance à dire que c'est qu'un
sentiment n'est pas une réalité
non ben c'est ce qu'ils disent est ont
un sentiment qui est erronée je suis
conscient du fait qu'il ya des vols des
violences qu est ce que vous pourriez
vie comme tout le monde j'ai été
commandés dans les cinq ou six fois
voilà j'ai séché comme vous tous donc
bon j'ai des solutions g10 lesquels
qu'est-ce que je peux faire de plus
concret que chaque fois je vais
intervenir ça va être tendu vous savez
il ya du bas la violence en sécurité et
puis quoi il faut réprimer davantage
je suis législateur vous savez je suis
là depuis longtemps et telus pas comme
une année une fois par an pour la
sécurité ça fait 30 ans que ça dure
d'accord ça fait 30 ans que les mêmes
viennent me voir en me disant mais
comment ça se fait que vous en parlez
pas et bien j'en parle une fois par an
quand la loi arrive puis je donne les
propositions pourquoi opposer pas la
question aux autres dupas vous parlent
de laver vous mais pourquoi on leur
demande pas des dents ça fait 30 ans que
vous nous casser les pieds tous les ans
avec une loi sur l'insécurité qui
toujours vos conduits à montrer du doigt
les mêmes ne prenez pas prendre un bus
il je sais ce que vous voulez prendre
que de faire comme vous faites ça vous
montrer du doigt une catégorie de la
population un bon et pourquoi vous
n'obtenez aucun résultat puisque vous
n'arrêtez pas de dire que c'est de pire
en pire comment ça se fait que c'est de
pire en pire alors que de plus en plus
deux lois qui sont sévères et cinquième
compte 1 et a un qui marche posez vous
des questions ça c'est la bonne question
pourquoi ce système la marche pas et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre moi
j'ai dix coupes faire d'autre
que comptez-vous faire concernant les
autres routes construites avec l'argent
du contribuable est depuis trop
longtemps on va chez les des acteurs
privés dont les profits sur le dos des
français ne cesse de battre des records
bajeux contre nationalisée voilà c'est
aussi simple que ça moi j'estime que ce
vol qui est depuis la privatisation d un
taux d'alors second acheter les
autoroutes ont fait la bonne affaire au
même pas cinq ans il avait amorti la
dépense tout le reste du temps pur bnf
voilà l'enjeu n'est pas d'accord on
n'est pas d'accord et il est temps
d'ailleurs que les excédents se dire les
superprofits des compagnies d'autoroutes
soient affectés akwaba à nettoyer à
arranger il ya développé peut-être du
transport collectif pourquoi pas cette
question mais que j'ai ressenti
que diriez vous à quelqu'un qui ne veut
pas voter
les attentionné ce qui nous regarde là
c'est pas une bonne idée parce que je
vous dirai pas pourquoi vous choisissez
de pas voter si bon
vous est immensément riche que tu vas
bien trop vous que vous êtes beau belle
cultivé intelligent vous avez le
véhicule de vos rêves la maison qu'ils
ont faites ce que vous voulez
mais les autres conseillers pas cruche
parce que ceux qui ont de quoi ils vont
tous voter y a qu'à regarder
les élections ou est-ce que l'abstention
est la plus forte dans les quartiers
populaires où est ce que la
participation la plus forte qu'ailleurs
réfléchissons avec nos têtes pourquoi ce
compte quelque chose à perdre ils vont
voter c'est parce qu'ils ont quelque
chose à perdre et qui comprennent donc
vous faites paille ça vous concerne
alors si vous êtes vraiment virano
poussant vous voulez absolument pas
participer à la vie politique ou qu'ils
aient respect moi je vous le dirai le
vote vous sont obligés d'y aller mais
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas obligé d'y
aller mais encore une fois rendez vous
compte des dégâts quoi parce que si vous
y allez pas c'est les mêmes qui
reviennent tout le temps est bon ils ont
déjà touché une fois deux fois trois
fois en coupe la pauvre pouces ils
peuvent au grand duché
donc l'on fait de passable puis d'abord
il ya un minimum de respect pour les
autres on vit tous ensemble nous allons
faire les choses ensemble on les fait
c'est l'argent public qui sert à faire
tourner tout ce qui est autour de nous
va que chacun prenne sa petite part qui
consiste à dire oui ceux-là seront mieux
faire que 12 je suis d'accord peut-être
pas toujours évident qui est ce qui va
mieux savoir faire que l'autre mais bon
ben justement c'est pour ça qu'au mans
dans notre petit cerveau chacun mais on
fait avec là c'est le principe de la
démocratie sinon vous avez un monarque
ou en tirant et décide tout seul et en
général les résultats ne sont pas
brillants
jeux vidéo ou est ce que c'est votre
équipe de communication de sophie
alors c'est moi je comprends vous posiez
la question parce que me la pose sur
tous les sujets est-ce que je
m'intéresse à ce que je fais parce que
je m'intéresse à ce que je dis ou est-ce
que je suis pas là pour séduire je peux
quoi mon équipe de communication déjà je
veux dire les choses elle fait ce qui
est décidé politiquement donc chez nous
c'est pas les communicants qui fit la
ligne il la met en scène parce que c'est
un métier qu'ils le font bien je pense
que j'ai la meilleure équipe à preuve
avec anne ont relevé en aussi mauvais
sujets que moi faire des résultats
électoraux aussi brillant une zone du
mal bon après je viens sur le jeu vidéo
moi je vous dis ça parce que c'est pas
pour vous j'en ai un mais ça m'énerve
tellement de voir les journalistes me
ramenait tout temps à ça c'est votre
public votre part de marché comme si on
était tous devenus des marchands de
savonnettes ou ne suis pas quoi sans
aucun idéal sans aucun but dans la vie
pour coiffer sa main la probabilité la
plus grande on m'a déjà dit 50 fois
c'est que vous y allez pas y arriver je
le fais quand même bon parce que je
crois ce que je fais ce qu'on a à mon
meilleur et tout ça voilà alors les jeux
vidéo je suis un intellectuel ça existe
lorsque je sais écrire plus de 140 mo
j'écris 22 livres je m'intéresse à la
vie de la société à l'anthropologie la
sociologie à la poésie la littérature la
philosophie c'est mémé sujet et j'ai
repéré quand le jeu vidéo est arrivé que
c'était un art total
je pèse mes mots un art total tous les
autres arts contiennent une partie de ce
que contient le jeu vidéo évidemment le
jeu vidéo va pas exclure les autres arts
n'a pas exclure la photographie la
peinture le cinéma parle sur la peinture
la musique il m'a pas aidé sur
l'écriture de deux romans policiers mais
il va tout les contenir et dans une
perspective qui est une perspective 3d
ce qui est pour moi c'est la partie du
jeu vidéo qui m'intéresse le plus hélas
oui c'est un art total je suis subjugué
alors après pour ce qu'aime que les
arguments économiques j'en profite pour
dire qu'aujourd'hui le budget du jeu
vidéo dans l'industrie du jeu vidéo est
supérieure à celle du cinéma donc c'est
pas rien et nous autres français on
n'est pas mauvais du tout le temps on a
une belle école angoulême est ailleurs
on a des supers boîtes qui font des
produits magiques d'ubisoft par exemple
c'est une boîte qui fait des choses
magnifiques donc je m'y intéresser je
voudrais qu'on développe ça en plus
comme une littéraire grp règle dans les
équipes qui font des jeux vidéo il y a
il ya toujours un ou deux littéraires
qui sont là pourquoi parce qu'ils ont lu
des histoires parce qu'ils connaissent
l'art de raconter et pour moi je trouve
magique que les littéraires comme ça que
d'un coup un champ d'expansion
professionnels qui n'avaient pas dans le
passé parce qu'à part faire preuve on
savait pas bien quoi en faire et comme
moi même j'ai fait une filière
littéraire j'avais voulu une année
inventé le bac professionnel ni d'érable
j'ai pas eu le temps a été battu aux
élections et et vous dossier de même
outil
un avis sur la crypto monnaie les nft la
france ait loupé plusieurs virages
technologiques en soutenant pas ses
talents
ouais fera t-elle encore la même chose
si vous êtes président sur les crypto
monnaie évidemment je propose et les
virages technologiques loupé ça discute
y en a beaucoup couru des prix mais pas
accompagné ou bien beaucoup ont été pris
on était des belles histoires et on a
vendu aussi sec il faut aussi et puis
c'est pas moi qui ai vendu ni la
puissance publique c'est bien la
personne qui faisait tu as trouvé que
c'était bien de le vendre faut s'en
rappeler et pas toujours tout collé sur
le dos de de la politique bon moi ce que
j'ai en tout cas les crypto monnaie ma
réponse est non
menez est une est un privilège de l'état
et de l'état c'est à dire de la nation
donc c'est lui qui décide de la manu et
ils décident d'une nonne et honnête
c'est à dire d'une monnaie qui est gagée
par des biens produits c'est pourquoi on
préfère avoir des cours stables de la
monnaie parce qu'il doit toujours y
avoir un équilibre entre les signes
monétaires et la production matérielle
la crypto menée par définition c'est
larnack permanence la spéculation
continuelle avec des bons et des rebonds
pour la raison que personne ne sait
quelle est la garantie réelle il ya un
cours de change point final alors vous
me direz les monnaies aussi mais les
fluctuations sur la monnaie réelle
demande et d etat sont pas les mêmes que
celles sur les crypto mais en tout cas
je suis pas d'accord pour que
commence à dire oui mais c'est la
liberté ne sais pas quoi ok j'ai compris
à la fin c'est les gaffes à qui décide
aussi de la monnaie donc il n'entend
rien à fiche du droit national il en
aurait une affiche de la monnaie
nationale et ils font la loi mais on m'a
dit ah oui mais ils font des dons par
une à moi je suis pas d'accord non plus
pour que la charité en place l'impôt
voilà j'espère que c'est dit avec assez
de fermeté est vrai c'est pas près de 15
minutes
proposition
est ce qu'on a dit
[Musique]
alors c'est une question importante est
pas facile pendant tout un temps
on avait une attitude et que toutes nos
équipes qui étaient assez raide de la
nuque pourquoi parce que on avait mal
vécu le référendum de 2005 on nous a
proposé ce qui s'applique aujourd'hui
les gens ont voté non et puis les élus
politiques ont dit ok on a reçu cinq sur
cinq c'est oui bah non c'est non et à
partir de là monsieur sarkozy à qui il
mène traitait qui avait été projeté la
fia adopté par
le congrès du parlement et nous l'a pris
dans un ensemble de traiter qui
limite d'une manière incroyable la
liberté de choix politique des peuples
bon et ça va très loin parce que c'est
il ya eu des propos d'une brutalité
incroyable jeu je vous garde président
de la commission a dit il n'ya pas de
démocratie possible en dehors des
traités c'est incroyable c'est la
première fois qu'on entend dire que un
traité est autre chose qu'un accord ça
devient une règle comme je sais pas quoi
on a les dix commandements ou un truc de
cette nature si bien que moi j'ai
l'intention de dire que c'est plutôt
qu'il ya pas de démocratie possible dans
les traités puis ce qu'ils interdisent
par exemple harmonisation fiscale par
exemple harmonisation sociale parce
qu'ils placent au sommet des normes
juridiques la concurrence libre et non
faussée alors que moi je veux y mettre
la coopération vous voyez donc il ya un
vrai problème mais on avait fait une
question qui était trop frontal si bien
qu'au lieu de discuter des conditions
réelles et des raisons réelles pour
lesquels on n'était pas d'accord on
était là dans une discussion abstraite
pour ou contre l'europe les droits des
nations d'une manière extrêmement
abstraite donc on a dit ou quittent ce
terrain et on va faire une proposition
plus simple et plus honnête nous
appliquons notre programme quoi qu'il
arrive donc 6 et cofor vous traiter tant
mieux si c'est pas conformes ont désobéi
hao traité voilà part qu'elle bouge
j'attrape la question il ya une deuxième
raison qui me conduit à être dans cette
prudence
cette deuxième raison c'est que la
domination sur l'union européenne de la
république
fédérale allemande est tel que avoir une
attitude sorte east 1 craint chaos parce
que nous sommes la deuxième économie du
continent et 2 revient à abandonner la
puissance à l'allemagne à l'allemagne ce
qui est rarement une bonne idée sur le
continent européen
en tout cas pour nous français se
seraient pas du tout une bonne idée
voilà pourquoi je préfère avoir
l'attitude que j'ai indiqué en pensant
qu'en plus je me fais fort d'avoir des
alliés parce que la deuxième économie
cela dit c'est nous la troisième c'est
les italiens la quatrième c'est espagnol
d'accord donc ça veut dire que la
richesse elle est produite au sud de
l'europe ne sont pas le club med com
avez dit madame merkel une fois de
manière extrêmement injurieuse et
inapproprié
je croyais
hollywood
j'ajoute un complément sur la question
par rapport aux ouïghours qui
demandaient pourquoi votre groupe
parlementaire s'est abstenue sur la
résolution qui avait été présentée à
l'assemblée
alors notre groupe parlementaire s'est
abstenu ce n'est pas une question ces
deux
parce que le texte que les socialistes
ont mis en débat et qui a été adopté
avec l'appui de la public en marche est
un texte qui dit que c'est un génocide
est en cours en chine sur les willow
donc on leur a dit écoutez les grandes
ong parlent pas de génocide et c'est pas
le moment de mettre le mot génocide
pourquoi a pour une raison très simple
c'est que dans les conventions
internationales dans le statut de l'onu
il dit que si c'est un génocide on a le
devoir d'intervenir pour le faire cesser
tiens devoir militaire alors moi je suis
pas d'accord pour que votre la guerre
contre la chine comme ça pour un veau
que les uns ou des autres honte ajoute
ils menèrent pas maintenant hypocrite et
je suis pour qu'on ait un comportement
disons-nous responsable comportement
responsable c'est un homme les choses
par leur nom et on l'a fait au parlement
européen où on a voté la résolution qui
condamnerait les violences
que l'on fait subir aux ouïghours donc
il n'ya pas de désintérêt pour la
question il ya une dénonciation d'un
comportement politiciens de gens qui
votent n'importe quoi et puis ensuite
iran de se coucher à la maison boire
leur bière et copains oui un génocide je
suis content c'est un génocide non il
peut pas se contenter d'être contre on
doit intervenir pour le faire cesser bon
vous admettrez comme moi que ça vaut la
peine qu'on y réfléchisse et que rufa
temps sur moi j'ai apprécié votre
formule parce que je la trouve beaucoup
plus correct comme vous dites dans là on
est dans une situation qui peut être un
crime contre l'humanité donc ont négligé
de savoir et que ça cesse et ainsi de
suite mais si on regarde les choses un
peu plus ample on s'aperçoit que sur la
surface de la planète entière il ya
aujourd'hui une manière de combattre le
djihadisme islamique qui en réalité et
aboutit à des mauvais traitements
permanent et de masse contre tous les
musulmans qui nous ont naturellement
souvent le plus souvent dans 90% des cas
avoir quoi que ce soit avec la violence
djihadiste et regardez ce que ça donne
ça donne la manière avec laquelle les
rues sont très ténues tchétchènes qui
est absolument abominable un de
répression ça donne une héroïne ja dont
on ne parle pas souvent j'ai déposé une
proposition de
résolution sur l'héroïne déjà parce que
l'héroïne j'ai eu ils sont au pire
manière également été foutu dehors et
parqué sur une île où tout le monde sait
que leurs conditions de vie sont
effroyables sauf que comme c'est la
birmanie ça intéresse moins un certain
nombre d' agences dans le monde qui
préfère s'en prendre à la chine parce
qu'elle est réputée de communistes que
mon avis elle doit pas être
autant qu'on croit donc et après je vous
passe les yéménites persécuté par les
saoudiens et ses doutes il ya d'une
manière générale la façon avec laquelle
est organisée la réplique au djihadisme
islamique parce que et contre quoi moi
je serai toujours qui est qu'on prenne
en otage tous les musulmans et quand les
rayons ils rendent responsables de
comportement et de choix politiques avec
lesquelles ils sont déjà en général je
vous dis à
95% pas d'accord voilà voilà la raison
une question qui est importante
c'est de la rédaction notamment par
rapport à ce qui se passe en ukraine
vous dites aujourd'hui les sanctions
c'est pas la bonne solution
à chécy faites ce que vous voulez non
c'est trop bon pour vous il faut
sanctionner la russie non mais si vous
voulez le faire peut-être le
sert à rien mais ça a l'air de vous
plaire ces mots simples pas moi y'a rien
à ces parcelles c'est un débat les
besoins vont me poser la classe je vous
pose déjà sur la question c'est pas
est-ce qu'il faut des sanctions c est ce
que c'est acceptable ou pas ce qui s'est
passé et qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre
c'est pas parce que vous et vos
collègues surtout rien n'est agnani
gnagnagna pour mercier là bas fait si
vous si vous avez des bonnes idées là je
suis responsable
j'ai aussi de dieu c'est juste
qu'aujourd'hui il ya débat au parlement
européen il ya des pays qu'ils prennent
des décisions la france a décidé d'en
prendre et moi je veux juste savoir
votre action si c'est une bonne idée ou
pas bon alors
la bonne idée c'est de faire ce que vous
voulez ce m'est égal moi je sais une
chose c'est que j'ai une position non
aligné ni avec les américains ni avec
les russes n'est que les chinois niek
personnes cas par cas on décide qu'on
fait les russes ont franchi
un seuil inacceptable ils n'ont pas à
reconnaître l'indépendance de deux
républiques autoproclamées à l'intérieur
d'un état reconnu au plan mondial qui et
l'ukraine bon ça c'est le point numéro
un le point numéro 2 ils ont franchi la
frontière parce qu'ils sont en train
d'entrer ils ont commencé par les
reconnaître et ils entrent militairement
dans les deux dans les deux pays c'est
inacceptable pour nous
inacceptable si on accepte ça ça veut
dire que dorénavant tous les problèmes
vont être réglés par la force et des
problèmes qui sont résultat de
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique a
partout il y en a en géorgie on a dans
les curistes plus les autres problèmes
parce que ma plein d'autres qui existent
dont on parle jamais qui sont les
revendications des uns sur les autres
dans l'europe donc moi je suis pour
qu'on commence par dire un on ne peut
pas être d'accord
et qu'on dise pourquoi parce que
franchir les frontières n'est pas
acceptable mais il ya des situations des
fois qu'ils nécessitent qu'on
intervienne
comment je dis de manière contrôlée
maîtrisé et que les peuples se prononce
sous un contrôle international s'il ya
un problème si on n'a pas la peine
mais après il ya le violon les sanctions
qu'est ce que ça mange bien j'ai fait
pour la crimée on a fait pour l'iran on
en a fait pour des tas de pays ça donne
des résultats merveilleux c'est à dire
qu'il peuple tire la langue jusqu'à par
terre et il ya aucun résultat politique
c'est maintenant presque sait pas
combien on va être à 40 ans de sanctions
contre l'iran
aucun résultat virus sont entrés en
crimée ils ont fait voter
résultat non 0 non plus et ainsi de
suite donc là ils sont tous en train de
se faire plaisir parce que qu'est-ce
qu'ils font cachent leur jeu lors je
sais quoi c'est un nouveau partage de
l'europe entre des américains et les
russes d'ailleurs quand ils veulent
parler de sécurité se réunisse entre eux
et font même pas bien des européens
ainsi pour prendre le café à la fin ça
leur public donc là qu'est ce qu'on est
en train de voir un nouveau partage de
l'europe entre russes et américains tout
ce qui rentre pour les amères l'eau
c'est autant et tout le reste c'est pour
les russes voilà alors ça ça peut pas
faire moins ferme je suis contre l'otan
je suis pour qu'on en sorte mais je sais
ce qui va se passer
qu'est ce qui s'est passé poutine s'est
dit ils vont le faire il a dit des fois
faut pas qu'ils entrent dans l'otan il
s'est dit bon faire donc qu'est-ce qui
fait face à plus de vente ajavon il
prend les enclaves russophone d'ukraine
1 avant que ce soit dans le temps parce
que si c'est dans l'otan se tape une
guerre donc la stap et des sanctions
celui là et puis normalement les états
unis d'amérique vont dire jour ou
l'autre
le parlement de l'ukraine glace pour
nous c'est pour entrer dans l'otan et
puis le conseil suprême super alors ici
mme de l'otan veut dire ah mais oui
venez et puis normalement un seul pays
pourrait tout bloquer salle à rim de
l'otan mais il y en a pas un qui va s'y
est risquée parce que l'oncle sam va
faire les gros yeux à tout le monde et
puis tous les autres comme d'habitude
que sous la table moi j'veux pas
d'accord avec ça je suis pour qu'on
fasse une conférence sur la sécurité des
frontières en europe parce que ça ça
sert à quelque chose on se met autour de
la table et/ou dit aux uns et aux autres
c'est quoi votre problème les russes
quelles garanties vous demandez mais on
me dit à tous quelles sont les garanties
qu demande des russes on ne fait pas le
cinéma médiatique wattignies fo va faire
si la perla comme si ce type n'agissait
pas en fonction de sa propre vision de
ce qui est nécessaire nous on a une
autre vision ça mais il ya des moments
on peut s'accorder avec lui et d'autres
fois non par exemple deux fois faut
s'accorder que les américains moi je
suis partisan du fait qu'on interdise
tout les missiles intermédiaire 500 km
sam hill kilomètre zéro rien pas en
europe ira pas un seul pourquoi passe
sans l'europe en champ de bataille donc
la conférence pour les la sécurité et
les frontières ça c'est une réponse
concrète les sanctions nous amèneront à
rien évidemment il faut discuter mais
pour que la conférence ait lieu bas tout
le monde commence par évacuer
alors on peut dire c'est une des
conditions de la conférence ou bien non
il n'y a pas de conditions enfin on
parle rationnellement là les sanctions
qui va les payer les européens globale
où vous êtes qui vous croyez qu'il va
payer les sanctions les russes la
dernière fois qu'on a fait des sanctions
ils ont appelé à se passer de 12 depuis
qu'on a gagné nous sommes le premier
investisseur nous autres français en
russie nous sommes le premier employeur
étranger en russie là ils disent qu'ils
vont couper le le pape du blow gazoduc
rigolade ils vont le coupé pendant quoi
quelques mois pour le rétablir pourquoi
le gaz a déjà augmenté de 20% qui va
payer plus cher les européens pas les
russes puisque ils exportent leur gaz
donc tout ça est une c'est pas sérieux
c'est pas de la politique internationale
sérieuse et puis après tout ce qu'ils
font des mouvements de menton qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent la guerre mais a fait là
montrez nous que c'est ça que vous
voulez montrez-nous vous voulez une
guerre nucléaire entre les américains
les russes etc et puis comme ça tombe
bien c'est chez nous que ça se passe
donc ça va leur coûter ni aux uns ni aux
autres tout ça est absurde donc moi je
mon idée c'est cette conférence et
surtout le sérieux dans les relations
diplomatiques comme je suis français et
rien d'autre pas américain je sais pas
quoi je ne suis pas d'accord pour qu'ils
s'arrangent entre eux pour décider ce
qui est bon pour l'europe voilà alors
pour conclure c'est provoquant le début
mais c'est fait exprès sinon vous
réfléchissez évidemment pour conclure
juste en a parlé un peu de vous
persuader ses quelque chose vraiment
c'est vraiment ping pong c'est des
questions très simples que je vais poser
- m dont certaines qui viennent de la
communauté la première c'est ben voilà
justement c'est vrai que vous êtes
communiste c'est ce que ma mère dit en
tout cas qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ça c'est trop loin le communisme aux
comptes dans mon esprit en tout cas le
l'idée mais j'ai jamais été membre du
pcf j'ai pas l'intention d'être d'aucun
parti communiste et il manque dans ma
jeunesse d'une organisation trotskisme
gpad ans merci à autre chose en toute
franchise quel problème avez vous de ne
pas pouvoir résoudre
j'ai pas peur d'une manière générale et
les problèmes sont solution n'existe pas
à mon débit votre plus grande fierté
pardon votre plus grande fierté dans
notre carrière j'en sais rien
d'avoir été le premier législateur qui
est le premier à déposer une loi pour le
mariage pour tous c'est un peu mais
c'est pas mon plus grand sujet non plus
grands sujets c'est les personnes que
j'ai sorti des camps des dictateurs
latino échec le rappel par yahia la
question ces chrétiens c'est justement
pour conclure il ya quelqu'un qui sait
ce que c'est toujours debout la
république qu'est ce que vous lui
répondais
oui comme tout le monde allez ciao ciao
au revoir monsieur merci